thank you lovely New Yorkers you clapped
for slightly longer than everyone else
and then you heard the British accent
and went
no did I used to own your
country I apologize no hard feelings no
no he's like not unless you give us the
Diamond Back Chris that's not my
decision I'm I'm wearing it either now
no I'm not that
successful um hello anyone else anyone
else from somewhere we
subjugated that's how I like to start
all of my conversations not just up here
just parties not really invited to many
that's a lovely fluffy jacket I not
supposed to say fluffy am I fur is it
actual fur from a real animal you don't
even know that's the kind of casual
violence that I admire in an Australian
like my [__] we that we owned their
country um we created that country
really I mean obviously there are people
who were from there and live there and
then but then you were the ones who
killed them we we just said you know
stop stealing bread no off to Australia
then that's a it is a lovely jacket
what's your what's your favorite
non-australian animal because Australia
is full a managerie of animals there's
so many of them like compared to your
animals every other animal is a [__]
like you've got the duck Bild platus
which is like a duck but also like a
mammal and it's got like a poison dart
in its leg um and it lays eggs and and
pisses out of one tube like a bird right
it's called a CLA did you know that
no why would you if you wi if you did
yes Chris I've actually got a tattoo of
the word as my motto
CLA um what what's your what's your
favorite non-australian
animal elephant the elephant [__] she
just tossed that off she was like just
say something to get him off my
case and then this is a lovely jacket as
well has Matthew you admired that jacket
but Matt lovely host cuz Matt is a soral
genius and so I think you probably would
have seen that and gone sexy it looks
expensive is it expensive enough that
I'm allowed to touch it yeah just want
to see if the fabric so this is that
it's nice but it wasn't
expensive I'm just checking I just want
to know like you think it was reasonable
okay we're going to find out different
people's values um you know so how much
was it fews a few hundred bucks that's
that's too that's too much money that's
a lot of money have you seen the state
of there homeless people everywhere and
you're walking around wearing hundreds
of dollars on your jacket this right
this cost about 40 bucks right and I
don't think it looks it I don't think it
looks like a few hundred bucks you know
but the money that I saved you know in
that I could give to homeless
people I didn't plan any of this I
thought I'd come up here and tell you
all I I want to find out what what do
you do with your lovely bit oh [__]
hell you're handsome I couldn't see with
the light but then
there what's quite cute were you were
you quite overweight as a child cuz the
way you reacted to me saying you're
quite handsome was quite shy and it's a
thing you often find with men who are
quite handsome now but were overweight
as children you say they're handsome and
they kind of go like no one's ever said
that to me before cuz we're still the
scared little children we are inside
even though we're grown up right like
I'm still the 12-year-old boy who was
told by his guidance counselor that I
should be a parking
attendant I was set on being a comedian
ever since I saw Robin Williams right
and I was like I'm going to be a
comedian and he was like no we' I've
done all your questions that You' put in
and it's parking attendant for
you I went home I was like Mom Dad I've
got to be a
paring and they were like they like
don't don't be and I didn't right and I
resent guidance counselors as a species
because it's a con it's a Ponzi scheme
right because that guidance counselor
was told to be a guidance counselor by a
guidance
counselor it's just it's guidance
counselors all the way up it goes all
the way back everyone the Garden of Eden
was Adam and Eve and Simon the guidance
counselor was like I wouldn't eat that
Apple if I were you [__] off mate why
are you wearing
clothes that's for the creationists if
you believe in Charles Darwin theory of
evolution and then a fish grew lungs and
got out onto the dry landine and
suddenly was like you have to do this
you um guidance count you're not a
guidance counselor are you no far too
far too guidance counselors don't need
that beard imagine being in the room
when a guidance counselor tells a child
they have to be a guidance counselor
just that moment must be just like so
like you must be a guidance counselor
but why because only then can I be
free what do you do with your handsome
facial hair it's been you've been neatly
you you've edged it right how often are
you in the barber shop every two two
every two two and a half weeks it's high
maintenance I don't you know six weeks
in between I've got a child I've got you
know stuff to do you know no children
yeah yeah were you fat as a kid no you
were very skinny oh so then Ah that's it
so you've done that
to did you get picked on it's probably
quite sad isn't it yeah and then you got
oh there there's women over there are
you are you up for a multiple
arrangement because women over there be
like i' pick on
you sorry I can't pronounce the word
piss properly um cool sneakers as well
so what what what do you do that lets
you be so
beautiful an engineer didn't expect
that you don't need to be beautiful to
be an engineer just let it go to seed
me are you guys a couple yeah been
married married no okay how long has you
been together years 3 years years after
3 years you really can let yourself go
you you I've been with my wife for 10
years it was really about 18 months we
hit and she was like you know I really
love you I was like I can finally eat
pizza and ice cream
again there we
go CHR didn't used to go to the gym yeah
when I wanted you to love me and then
you you made the mistake of saying it um
that's lovely so an engineer that's high
minded you got a good good high level
degree from a good
University of Science
Bachelor of Science from
Baylor she'll [__] you as well
what I'm going to start a comedic
matchmaking service where I come in here
I just I mean like you've all you are
all coupled up and stuff you look at me
like don't I mean look you've got too
many buttons undone for me to want to
help you you your chest ha is doing that
yourself you're like come at me girls
and boys you know we all like a bit of
chest hair and then you know so there
kind of like everyone's with people and
then you know yeah yeah I'm focusing on
you what what's what's your name my
engineer friend Andrew Andrew you don't
hear that name often do you how do you
feel about our our Prince besing that as
a name he didn't do you know if there
was a vicious pedophile called Chris I
would be upset like no how was going to
think did you find that did you find
whenever you give your name at Starbucks
they'd be like Andrew yeah is your
coffee hot so you can take it to
Epstein's Island it will stay on the way
sorry I shouldn't use the words
Epstein's Island and extra hot in the
same sentence that makes me look to have
offensive proclivities Andrew when you
were a little a little kid growing up
what what did you want to be an NBA
player an NBA player how tall are you
six feet bad
luck you have tall parents and they just
let you think that you could be I want
to be an NBA play it's one of the just
if a kid wants to be an NBA player and
your mom is not at least 6'2 you're not
going to be an NBA player you know the
scouts they look at the moms moms sorry
um Scouts are very much like me pay
close attention to the mothers and they
look at the mom that's who they want to
see they want to see the M the mom's T
they go this person's going to going to
have it did you know
that look at that I pay attention to
your cultural interests you all like NBA
I was like I'll learn some facts so look
at this we've got an Australian who
loves elephants we've got Andrew who
wanted to be in the NBA but now engineer
and then and Andrew's bow Andrew's
Paramore Andrew's love love three years
you said love haven't you yeah yeah
that's he's yeah I was forced to it was
an ultimatum really um and what did you
do I'm po specialist a poly specialist
quality special quality specialist a
poly specialist is something very
different you didn't mind all those
people a quality specialist I I've never
heard the phrase quality specialist
before what does that mean do like um
documentation review for vacc
documentation review for vaccines there
some people in here think you're
sleeping on the
job documentation review I just checked
that the batch of microchips is going in
there yeah sign it off cheers bill um
put that in quality assurance yeah no
it's small enough they can't see it
they'll never
know which uh which is the best which
which one would you assure us of the
most quality which one do we want to
pop in there non-disclosure oh it's
shadier than we thought isn't
it kind of weird that you're not allowed
to talk about it well I'm not a vaccine
skeptic but I'm starting to
believe it's pretty good when you were
when you were little that wasn't a dream
right you know these vaccines these
vaccines weren't yeah so what what did
you want to be I want to be into
photography into photography and know
you still into photography that's you
know that's the thing you can do no oh
what
happened you took a photo and someone
just went this is [__] your thumb is
over the lens you
idiot you were saying your parents your
parents dissuaded you why um well my
mom's a nurse practitioner your mom's a
nurse practitioner my dad's a chemical
engineer dad's a chemical engineer no
daughter of
ours it's going to move to New York and
be a
photographer You're really hurting the
feel feel ings of my photographer
brought along
tonight his parents are very
supportive wow can't believe that that's
that's
sad follow your dreams [__] quit your
job let let someone else pepet the
microprocessors into the vials of fisa
madna there's only two we can
guess I was seeing if she was going to
go no actually there's a we knew that
one
wait um amazing and then my Aussie my
Aussie friend who loves S I caught you
while you were drinking there but that's
quite normal for an Aussie
what what's your what's your vocation
what do you do that allows you to be in
New York so long you've flown here for a
little
holiday Christmas ah cuz we got
Christmas here in Australia it's
opposite it's upside down so they're
this is the hottest time of the year for
them over there yeah it's true it's true
a't it right um no decorations that's
sad isn't it that's you can't just like
stick some tinsel on a kangaroo and
kick it around a
bit okay no kangaroos where you live did
you get them is that what the cat's made
of bleached
kangaroo the rare albino kangaroo is
considered extinct in the area of
Australia where she
lives the last species were seen hopping
into a
habiter coat maker what what did you do
my aie friend
uh we're in property you're in
property like these
suckers Buy Low sell High exploit the
Millennials okay Australian property
developer who likes elephants a Greek
Australian Greek Australian thank you
for adding that and it adds an extra
angle of racism
toite through a spanner in the works or
a span a ceter if you will type of Greek
cuisine youd Lely okay and we got our
lovely our lovely friends here this is
going to be this is going to be pretty
fun Andrew you didn't ask me what I
wanted to be when a grow up I want to be
a rapper
mate let's do this let's uh let's pop
that pop that pop that on the stereo a
yeah and then uh Andrew Andrew's lady
what was your name ni Nia Nina Nina Nina
add in that n is good and then my Aussie
friend
name
Valen what
Valen under the color lady leaves me
blushing she had us trust in Australian
but the name is Russian like Valentine
making you scream coming at you like I'm
Greek when I'm in the dream I'll be
seeing this pring like a peacock I get a
kangaroo get the coat that he dropped
Chop Chop tra the tail take it to my fa
make a make without fail I got the coat
is far too hot to wear it in December so
the little kangaroo further I st I
remember fly off to NYC wear it nightly
yeah I like these I like to spend the
cash I spend my D I get a nice little
house and I make sure to show the room
properly I get my realtor they come and
they sell it real quick and then I need
to get my cash to the bank in Australia
we ain't got Christmas time so we travel
so far You' be looking over there
feeling the Bliss you're like hey I hope
the Chris touches this the fabric we
grabbed it yeah it's enough I feel the
elastic stiff in the cuff that's what we
need saving the money and now we on to
Andrew he's right on the money as a
child he was skinny people used to bully
he's like I need to make my t-shirts
more fully fulfilled got a bodyb build
one day I'll be the real king of the
hill I'll give all the ladies in the
back of the room chills they'll be
coming like you could pay our bills and
buy our bills lick our bums is that mean
yum yum it's a heaven sent guy elephant
why you be seeing them T so high I
Inspire they got the larges or maybe
small they love to trumpet yeah they'd
be balancing balls that's how they work
in the circus back in the past I love
Nina seeing she's like I'm top class I
can make sure I got quantities of vaccin
spread overseas quality it's kind of
questionable cuz that's my job I like to
tick tick tick and then I miss a box
I'll just send that one to a country
that we hate China's fault in the first
place so that's what they get I'm trying
to rap the Chinese vaccine was called
sin OFA yeah you're signing that I know
I'm spreading facts you're like NDA
Chris I take it back hey that's a
non-disclosure agreement want to be a
photographer but parents seen it they
say nah you should avoid anything
involving film or a Polaroid you need to
take this burn it you know that
throwback you never take a snap with
cold that you chose that job then you
move it on but Andrew understand he's
number one clearly I'm the engineer with
the neat beard looking ever so long you
could keep it here you could eat all the
food that you catch in the scrs but no
ball would fit in his hands he tried to
Palm it when he's there on the court he
was like oh yes I really thought I'd be
the best CH i' be dunking and shooting
everyone's like oh we're scouting you
but sadly your parents are small so you
never pursue that basketball but still
look at you I'd have you you've got
lovely arms covered in tattoos do your
parents like that you stained your skin
now usually they're like look at him
he's B sming his canvas that we made
basketball Jesus Christ he's dismayed he
made the most terrible mistake Australia
full of poisonous snakes that's just a
fact from the freestyle rapper we
learned monre have thing called clacka
and that made you open mouth and just
wow I love that your buttons are open
for now so there we go that's the rap
not obcena so give it up for Valentine
Andrew and
[Applause]
you guys are
lovely